walk us through when you buy the team
what does that come with is it like you
get player contracts there's a field
that you own like what exactly comes
with the deal yeah if you're buying a
premier league team yeah but this is
this you you're buying the name
you're buying like whatever like leases
they've got on the ground and any
equipment but it's you know we're in the
10th year of british football you know
the infrastructure is minuscule um
really you're just buying the setup
there's you know real assets apart from
like the equipment but you're not really
buying that you're just buying you're
buying the name and the
infrastructure that's already in place
which is easier than setting up a if you
start a team you have to start below
that which is the 11th tier okay now
when you
talk about being in the 10th tier the
epl that is the uh number one tier
yeah yeah so with nine promoters from
the premier league how hard is it gonna
be to get from ten to one
good question right i think it's the way
i've thought about it because i only
ever thought i want to get in the
football league which is
uh that's premier league championship
league one elite two and that's known as
the personal league so we are uh six
promotions away from the football league
that was the original target and then i
spoke to an investor who said well how
about how do you get in the premier
league so i think it's so i thought
about it a lot and there's kind of
two stages to it stage one is
uh get to the football league that
really is about having if you know
you've got them enough money you can get
the best players and the best manager
you can make it through those leagues
now these clubs operate on no money i
mean the budget for my team for this
year the team
to run the club was fifteen thousand
pounds
none of the players i
i've already in the first week i sold
managers the budget they can go and get
the players
i think our turnover this year will
match
a
like a decent league 2 team therefore
we've got good budgets to spend on
players and managers so if we can
continue to run this instant like a
successful commercial business
and we have the right team in place we
should be able to get through those
early divisions
let's say we do it pops there
they began to leak too
how do you overlead to the premier
league you know you
need real money and real infrastructure
that's expensive
and so my my view on this is you know
it's it's quite a bold one i want to do
something nobody will understand out in
football you'll get it i want to raise
50 million pounds and i want to put that
in a bitcoin treasury that we don't
touch for eight seasons it just sits in
there
you know
what big coin does this thing by the
time we get into the football league
we'll have quite a war chest to work
with
all right
how much money can you make doing this
so let's say that you bought the team i
don't have you said how much you bought
the team for is that is that publicly
known
[Music]
we'll say that it was a good deal i
trust your negotiating skills how much
money can you make if you make it all
the way to the epl is that like a couple
hundred million dollars a year now
listen look uh for me this isn't about
making money pop but this was about
making money i wouldn't actually raise
any investment because
i i can like generate close to a million
and a half of profit
with this team this year and i can do
that you know most seasons
and just pocket that money but it's not
about that this is about doing something
for bedford where i'm from like i'm in
this fortunate position where i can
rally this army of bitcoin to get behind
it
i can i want to do this but say a
question the only real money is in the
premier league right if you get in the
premier league you get access to the tv
money and it's about 150 million a year
so
you know
that's a decent amount of money that you
get just for being there and being on tv
now if you create a car that's in the
premier league you know you have a club
that's worth
possibly anything from
i mean
i think newcastle just sold for like 300
or four hundred million
so he the reason why i'm asking about
how much money you can make is because
i'm thinking about making an investment
coming to bedford and say i'm part of
your team
you know that guy peter he's the prince
of bedford i'm the king of bedford
you're going to make an investment for
sure i'm going to make sure you make it
investment but this is also i think
there's two things that i play here that
can work well i can i can do something
for bitcoin that benefits bedford i can
do some benefit of bedford that benefits
bitcoin right correct
so we can leverage the bitcoiners to get
behind this which allows bedford have a
really good commercial model and be
successful
but we can leverage bedford for bitcoin
because if this is successful you know
if in terms of advertising you talk
about things like a category job they
think of um think of the ads that um dct
do their ads aren't really um
aren't really about dcg they're category
as bitcoin
you know if we run this on a sound money
standard i make this work it does a
category job of explaining bitcoin to
football uh people as well so i think
there's like this symbiotic relationship